Priya Singh: Today’s focus: checkout redesign.
Riley Chen: Any blockers from last time?
Riley Chen: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Avery Kim: I think we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Let’s keep this within this sprint on checkout redesign.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Specifically for checkout redesign.
Jordan Patel: Risk: accessibility gaps for checkout redesign.
Priya Singh: I think we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Any risks we’re missing? on checkout redesign.
Avery Kim: I think we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: I think we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Priya Singh: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for checkout redesign.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, Specifically for checkout redesign.
Jordan Patel: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: My take is we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: We need to timebox the spike on checkout redesign.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, UX needs a final pass.
Avery Kim: We need to timebox the spike on checkout redesign.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; parallelize testing.
Samira López: Observability dashboards for errors on checkout redesign.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for checkout redesign.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for checkout redesign.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: I think we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Samira López: Any risks we’re missing? on checkout redesign.
Priya Singh: Action: set up dashboards.
Avery Kim: We need to timebox the spike on checkout redesign.
Samira López: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for checkout redesign.
Priya Singh: Risk: flaky tests for checkout redesign.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: I propose we split checkout redesign into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We might need a migration.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on checkout redesign; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Okay, who can take ownership?
Samira López: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Samira López: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.